cette mère photographier sa fille devant
une école devenue célèbre
c'est ici à l'école westmount que
cabella harris la vice présidente
désignée des états unis a obtenu son
diplôme d'études secondaires elle aura
passé cinq ans à montréal
suivant sa mère une scientifique
embauché par l'université mcgill
des camarades de classe se souviennent
et nicolas l image mardi dernier près de
quarante années plus tard sur le même
avis d'autres sont prêts à lui emboîter
le pas à l'acte kamala harris aussi et
mitis et sa mère est née en aide son
père en jamaïque pour moi c'est une très
belle inspiration c'est ce qui signifie
diminuer dominique anglade est la
première femme noire à la tête d'un
parti au québec s'en sort à metz mais
qui qui arrive en poste et envoie un
message très fort un modèle par son
parcours
un modèle pour les jeunes pour leur
donner vraiment la fel de vol plus loin
que tu peux un modèle pour les jeunes
mais particulièrement les enfants des
migrantes
c'est porteur d'espoir le pour les
personnes race idée de dire on va
vraiment pouvoir écouter surtout pour
l'ami de sa soeur qui a fréquenté la
famille harris à l'époque
l'ascension de kamal a est une
démonstration du pouvoir des femmes
gmail est proche pour que tout est
possible
non sans efforts ici marie josée paquet
comme ou radio canada montréal